CABLE TELEVISION COMPANIES AND
IS BROUGHT TO YOU TODAY BY YOUR
CABLE OR SPLITE PROVIDER.
-- SATELLITE BER PROVIDER.
>> IN AN INTERVIEW IN 1997 THE
LATE PUBLISHER OF "THE
WASHINGTON POST" KATHARINE
GRAHAM TALKS ABOUT HER BOOK,
BOOKBOOK -- "PERSONAL HISTORY."
OTHER TOPICS INCLUDE THE
WATERGATE SCANDAL, THE PENTAGON
PAPERS, AND A JOURNALIST
STRIKE.
BRIAN: KATHARINE GRAHAM, AUTHOR
OF "PERSONAL HISTORY."
DID YOUR CHILDREN LEARN
ANYTHING IN THIS BOOK ABOUT
YOU?
KATHARINE: THAT'S A HARD
QUESTION.
I'M SURE THEY PROBABLY DID BUT
I CAN'T TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT.
BRIAN: ALL THE STUFF IN HERE
ABOUT YOUR EARLY LIFE AND YOUR
HUSBAND AND ALL THAT, DID THEY
KNOW THAT?
HAVE YOU ALL TALKED THAT OUT?
KATHARINE: YES.
I THINK THEY UNDERSTAND THAT HE
WAS ILL.
THE OLDEST ONE WAS 20, AND THE
YOUNGEST ONE WAS 11.
SO THEY HAD TO DEAL WITH IT
THEN AND ALWAYS.
BRIAN: THE QUESTION I HAD AFTER
I READ THE BOOK, WHY DO YOU
WANT US TO KNOW ALL THIS?
KATHARINE: I REALLY DON'T
SUPPOSE THAT I MEANT TO JUST
TELL EVERYTHING TO EVERYBODY,
BUT ONCE I SAT DOWN TO WRITE MY
STORY, I JUST TEND TO BE FRANK
AND OPEN AND I WANTED TO BE
VERY TRUTHFUL AND I JUST WROTE
IT THE WAY I SAW IT AND THE WAY
THE RESEARCH CAME UP WITH.
I TOLD IT AS I -- THE BEST I
COULD.
BRIAN: WHEN DID YOU START IT?
KATHARINE: ABOUT 6 1/2 YEARS
AGO I STARTED TO DO THE
RESEARCH FOR THIS BOOK.
I ACTUALLY HAD THE IDEA EVEN
LONGER AGO THAN THAT.
BRIAN: YOU ADDRESSED EARLY IN
THE BOOK THAT YOU WROTE IT
YOURSELF.
KATHARINE: I DID.
BUT I ALSO HAD VERY GOOD
ASSISTANCE FROM A FINE
RESEARCHER, EVELYN, MY EDITOR
AT KNOPF, BOB, SO I FELT LIKE I
HAD ASSISTANCE FROM THEM BUT I
WROTE THE WORDS MYSELF.
BRIAN: HOW DID YOU GO ABOUT IT?
KATHARINE: WELL, FOR ABOUT TWO
YEARS WE DID RESEARCH BECAUSE I
HAD NO'S CABLE TELEVISION
COMPANIES AND IS BROUGHT TO YOU
TODAY BY YOUR CABLE OR SPLITE
PROVIDER.
-- SATELLITE BER PROVIDER.
>> IN AN INTERVIEW IN 1997 THE
LATE PUBLISHER OF "THE
WASHINGTON POST" KATHARINE
GRAHAM TALKS ABOUT HER BOOK,
BOOKBOOK -- "PERSONAL HISTORY."
OTHER TOPICS INCLUDE THE
WATERGATE SCANDAL, THE PENTAGON
PAPERS, AND A JOURNALIST
STRIKE.
BRIAN: KATHARINE GRAHAM, AUTHOR
OF "PERSONAL HISTORY."
DID YOUR CHILDREN LEARN
ANYTHING IN THIS BOOK ABOUT
YOU?
KATHARINE: THAT'S A HARD
QUESTION.
I'M SURE THEY PROBABLY DID BUT
I CAN'T TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT.
BRIAN: ALL THE STUFF IN HERE
ABOUT YOUR EARLY LIFE AND YOUR
HUSBAND AND ALL THAT, DID THEY
KNOW THAT?
HAVE YOU ALL TALKED THAT O 11.
SO THEY HAD TO DEAL WITH IT
BRIAN: YOU ADDRESSED EARLY IN
THE B THE LETTERS
AND LUCKILY I GREW UP IN THE
D MY
CONTEMPORARY STARTING WITH
SCHOOLMATES AND WORKING ON UP
TO POLITICIANS AND JUDGES AND
OTHER PEOPLE THAT WE DEALT WITH
AND THAT HELPED FILL IN THE
RECORD.
BRIAN: WHAT YEAR DID YOUR
FATHER BUY "THE POST"?
KATHARINE: IN 1933.
HE HAD JUST GOTTEN OUT OF THE
GOVERNMENT.
BEEN OUT THREE WEEKS.
BEEN GOVERNOR OF THE FEDERAL
RESERVE BOARD.
STARTED THE RECONSTRUCTION
FINANCE CORPORATION UNDER
HOOVER AND HE STAYED AS FEDERAL
RESERVE CHAIRMAN UNDER ROSEVELT
AND THEN RESIGNED BECAUSE --
ROOSEVELT AND THEN RESIGNED
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T LIKE
ROOSEVELT'S MONETARY POLICIES.
THE POST CAME UP THREE WEEKS
LATER FOR AUCTION ON THE STEPS
OF THE BUILDING.
AND HE BOUGHT IT ANONYMOUSLY.
BRIAN: WHAT DID HE PAY FOR IT?
KATHARINE: $825,000.
BRIAN: HOW MANY NEWSPAPERS WERE
IN WASHINGTON?
KATHARINE: THERE WERE FIVE AND
THE "POST" WAS SIXTH.
IT HAD A CIRCULATION OF ABOUT
50,000 IN A PRETTY BROKEN DOWN
BUILDING.
SO HE STARTED IN.
HE WAS A BUSINESSMAN AND
THOUGHT HE KNEW HOW TO TURN
AROUND BUSINESSES BUT HE NEVER
HAD ANY NEWSPAPER EXPERIENCE
AND HE ENCOUNTERED THE MOST
HORRENDOUS DIFFICULTIES IN
FIGHTING HIS WAY UP BUT HE DID
A TERRIFIC JOB STARTING WITH
NOTHING.
BRIAN: WHERE IS MOUNT KISKO?
KATHARINE: WHERE THEY LIVED IN
THE SUMMER WAS ABOUT AN HOUR --
IT WAS ABOUT 50 MILES FROM NEW
YORK CITY IN WESTCHESTER
COUNTY.
AND WE WENT THERE EVERY SUMMER.
AND THEY HAD BUILT THIS LARGE
HOUSE THERE THINKING MY FATHER
WAS GOING TO LIVE THERE WHILE
ON WALL STREET AND GOING TO
COMMUTE TO WALL STREET BUT IT
JUST GOT BUILT WHEN THEY MOVED
TO WASHINGTON.
BRIAN: WHEN DID YOUR FATHER
MEET YOUR MOTHER?
KATHARINE: IN 1912.
THEY MET IN A MUSEUM.
IN NEW YORK CITY.
MY FATHER HAD PICKED UP A
FRIEND AND THEY WERE DRIVING
DOWNTOWN IN AN OLD CAR THAT HE
HAD CALLED A STANLEY STEAMER
AND HE PICKED UP THIS FRIEND
WHOM HE DIDN'T EITHER KNOW VERY
WELL OR LIKED VERY MUCH AND
SAID THAT HE WOULD LIKE TO GIVE
HIM A RIDE BUT HE WAS GOING TO
STOP OFF AT THE JAPANESE PRINT
SHOW AND THEY DID THAT AND THEY
SAW MY MOTHER WALKING AROUND IN
THE SHOW AND MY FATHER SAID TO
HIS FRIEND, THAT'S THE WOMAN I
AM GOING TO MARRY.
AND SO THE FRIEND SAID, WELL,
THEN YOU HAVE TO SPEAK TO HER.
MY FATHER SAID, NO, NO.
THAT WOULD SPOIL EVERYTHING.
ONE OF US IS GOING TO MEET HER
AND WHOEVER MEETS HER FIRST
WILL CALL THE OTHER ONE.
AND ABOUT TWO WEEKS LATER THE
FRIEND CALLED MY FATHER AND
SAID, GUESS WHAT.
AND HE SAID, YOU MET THE GIRL.
AND HE SAID, DAMN YOU, I HAVE.
AND I ARRANGED WE ARE ALL GOING
TO HAVE DINNER.
AND FROM -- TWO -- THAT WAS --
THAT WAS LINCOLN'S BIRTHDAY AND
TWO YEARS LATER THEY WERE
MARRIED ON LINCOLN'S BIRTHDAY.
BRIAN: HOW WAS IT THAT HE WAS
JEWISH AND SHE WAS --
KATHARINE: THEY WEREN'T
RELIGIOUS.
MY MOTHER A LITTLE MORE THAN MY
FATHER.
HE HAD AT THE AGE OF 14 OR --
STUDIED FOR A BAR MITZVAH AND
THEN HE DECIDED -- HE SAID, I
BELIEVE SOME OF THAT BUT NOT
ALL OF IT AND I'M NOT GOING TO
DO THAT.
AND HE NEVER -- HE WAS VERY,
VERY ETHICAL, VERY DRIVEN, VERY
MORAL BUT HE WASN'T FORMALLY
RELIGIOUS.
SHE -- NEITHER WAS SHE BUT HER
FAMILY WAS AND HIS FAMILY WAS.
AND SO SHE TOOK US TO CHURCH
BUT VERY -- NOT VERY FORMALLY.
BRIAN: AS YOU GREW OLDER, FROM
TIME TO TIME, ANTI-SEMITISM
CAME IN YOUR LIFE.
HOW OFTEN?
KATHARINE: ALMOST NOT THE A ALL
STRANGELY WHEN I WAS YOUNG.
ONE WHEN I WAS IN SCHOOL AND
SOMEBODY WAS CASTING THE
MERCHANT OF VENICE AND SAID
MAYBE I SHOULD PLAY SHY LOT
BECAUSE I WAS JEWISH AND I
DIDN'T HAVE ANY IDEA I WAS OR
THERE WAS SUCH A THING.
I KNEW NOTHING ABOUT IT AND AT
SOME OTHER POINT THEY SAID MY
FATHER WAS A MILLIONAIRE AND I
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT EITHER ONE
MEANT.
I HAD GONE HOME AND ASKED MY
MOTHER WHAT IT MEANT TO BE
JEWISH AND WHAT IT MEANT TO BE
A MILLIONAIRE AND I DON'T THINK
I GOT AN EXPLANATION FOR EITHER
ONE AT THAT POINT.
THEN LATER ON IN COLLEGE IT
CAME UP BECAUSE OF COURSE
HITLER STARTED AND IT WAS MORE
OF AN ISSUE.
BUT I SPENT MY WHOLE YOUTH
UNAWARE OF THE ISSUES OR
ANTI-SEMITISM OR ANYTHING.
I MEAN, I SHOULD HAVE KNOWN A
LOT MORE ABOUT IT.
I SHOULD HAVE KNOWN BOTH THEIR
HERITAGES AND WHAT IT MEANT TO
BE JEWISH, WHAT IT MEANT TO BE
LUTHERAN BUT IT SIMPLY WASN'T
MENTIONED.
BY THE WAY, I'M SURE THEY
WEREN'T ASHAMED.
NOTHING INTIMATE WAS REALLY
TALKED ABOUT IN MY FAMILY.
BRIAN: HOW MANY OTHER KIDS IN
THE FAMILY?
KATHARINE: THERE'S FIVE OF US
IN ALL AND I WAS THE FOURTH.
BRIAN: HOW MANY ARE STILL
ALIVE?
KATHARINE: I HAVE TWO SISTERS.
ONE OLDER, MY SISTER ELIZABETH,
AND YOUNG, MY SISTER RUTH.
SHE WAS FOUR YEARS YOUNGER THAN
ME AND TWO YEARS BETWEEN ALL
THE REST OF US BROIFMENT AND
YOU GREW UP WHERE?
KATHARINE: IN -- WELL, WE SPENT
OUR FIRST YEARS IN NEW YORK AND
THAT'S KIND OF A STRANGE PART
OF THE STORY BECAUSE MY FAMILY
MOVED TO WASHINGTON BUT THEY
WERE THERE FOR ALMOST FOUR
YEARS BEFORE THEY MOVED US DOWN
TO WASHINGTON SO WE WERE LIVING
MOSTLY WITH GOVERNESSES AND
NURSES AND TEACHERS IN THE NEW
YORK APARTMENT.
IN FACT, THEY HAD COME UP IN
BETWEEN AND VISITED US AND
OCCASIONALLY MY SISTERS WOULD
GO DOWN TO WASHINGTON BUT I WAS
A BABY.
WHEN I WAS 4 WE ALL MOVED TO
WASHINGTON.
BRIAN: WHERE DID YOU GO TO
COLLEGE?
KATHARINE: I WENT FOR TWO YEARS
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO
AND TWO YEARS AT VASSER.
I CHANGED.
BRIAN: AND WHO TAUGHT YOU?
KATHARINE: MORT AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNIVERSITY
TAUGHTS TOGETHER.
IT WAS -- THE GREAT IDEAS IN
THE WESTERN WORLD THEY THOUGHT
HUTCHINS HAD A SERIES I THINK
STARTED AT ST. JOHNS COLLEGE IN
ANNAPOLIS.
LEARNED THE GREAT IDEAS OF THE
WESTERN WORLD, BUT THAT WOULD
BE YOUR EDUCATION.
SO THIS COURSE STARTED WITH
PLATEO AND ARISTOTLE AND WORKED
ALL THE WAY UP TO ST. --
THROUGH ST. THOMAS AND TO FREUD
AND MARX AND THEY DRILLED YOU.
IT WAS A SEW KRATTIC METHOD AND
YOU HAD -- SOCRATIC METHOD AND
YOU HAD TO STAND UP FOR
YOURSELF AND DEFEND YOURSELF.
IT WAS RIGOROUS, VERY HARD.
BRIAN: WHO GAME YOUR FAVORITE
PHILOSOPHER?
KATHARINE: I LIKED THE GREEKS.
I LIKED ARISTOTLE AND LIFE.
I WAS INTERESTED IN THAT.
BRIAN: AFTER COLLEGE WHAT?
KATHARINE: WELL, I HAD PROUDLY
GONE OFF AND GOTTEN MYSELF A
JOB AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CHICAGO.
I MEAN, I'D USE MY LABOR
RELATIONS PROFESSOR, PAUL
DOUGLAS, WHO LATER BECAME A
SENATOR, KNEW THE PUBLISHER OF
THEN "CHICAGO TIMES," THE
AFTERNOON TABLOID AND I WENT
DOWN THERE AND ASKED HIM FOR A
JOB AND HE SAID HE WOULD TAKE
ME BUT IF I WASN'T ANY GOOD
THEN I SHOULDN'T THINK HE WAS
GOING TO KEEP ME AND I SAID
THAT WOULD BE FINE, I WOULD
LOVE A TRYOUT.
THEN I WENT HOME AND MY FATHER
ASKED ME TO GO OUT TO SAN
FRANCISCO WITH HIM ON A TRAIN
TRIP HE WAS TAKING BECAUSE HE
WAS GOING TO THE DOUGH HEEMIAN
GROVE.
I SAID -- BOW PEOPLIAN GROVE.
-- BOHEMIAN GROVE.
I SAID, I LOVE THIS TOWN.
IF I SWALLOW MY PRIDE, LEAVE
CHICAGO, WOULD YOU HELP ME AND
HE DID.
BRIAN: YOU MARRIED HARRY
BRIDGES.
KATHARINE: WELL, I COVERED A
LABOR DISPUTE, A LOCKOUT, ON
THE WHOLE WATERFRONT OF
EVERYBODY WHO WAS WORKING IN
THE WAREHOUSES.
IT WAS AFTER -- TWO YEARS AFTER
THE VERY BLOODY WELL-KNOWN
LONGSHOREMAN STRIKE AND I WAS
ASKED BY THE LABOR REPORTER TO
DO THE LEG WORK ON THIS.
AND I WENT UP AND DOWN THE
WATERFRONT AND GOT TO KNOW THE
NEGOTIATOR FOR THE UNION, SAM
CAGEL, AND THE HEAD OF THE
WAREHOUSE UNION, AND
OCCASIONALLY HARRY BRIDGES WILL
HAVE TO SAY, ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT
CORRECT THESE DAYS, I
SOCIALIZED WITH HIM AT NIGHT
AND WE WENT DRINKING UP AND
DOWN BOILERMAKERS.
BRIAN: AND THEY WERE
BOILERMAKERS?
KATHARINE: I FEAR THEY WERE
WHISKY AND BEER MIXED.
YOU COULD GET ONE FREE IF YOU
PAID 25 CENTS FOR TWO.
BRIAN: MY POLITICAL OUTLOOK
DEVELOPED AS A COMMITTED
LIBERAL, PRIMARILY PASSIONATE,
ANTI-FASCIST AND
ANTI-SYMPATHETIC TOWARD THE
LABOR MOVEMENT.
STILL THERE?
KATHARINE: HONESTLY NOT.
I MEAN, I AM -- YOU DEAL AND
WANT TO DEAL WITH ORGANIZED
LABOR AND WE DO, BUT I THINK AS
IT -- THEN THEY WERE JUST
GETTING ORGANIZED AND THE
INDUSTRIAL UNIONS WERE ALL NEW.
THE STEEL AND MINERS WERE
UNORGANIZED AND THEY WERE JUST
GETTING ORGANIZED.
AND SO THEIR LABOR CONDITIONS
WERE QUITE BAD.
RIGHT NOW SOME OF THE UNIONS
ARE FINE WHERE THEY ARE AND
SOME LIKE MANY BUSINESSES I
FEEL HAVE GOTTEN INTO PRACTICES
THAT ARE NOT PARTICULARLY
CONSTRUCTIVE BUT HAVE TO BE
RETHOUGHT LIKE FEATHERBEDDING
WHEN IT'S NOT NEEDED.
BRIAN: AFTER ALL THESE YEARS,
WHAT'S YOUR POLITICAL
PHILOSOPHY TODAY?
HOW WOULD YOU DEFINE YOURSELF?
KATHARINE: I THINK I AM JUST
ABOUT WHERE I WAS.
I'M CENTRIST PROBABLY MORE
DEMOCRATIC THAN NOT BUT I'M
INDEPENDENT.
I VOTED FOR REPUBLICANS AS WELL
AS DEMOCRATS.
BUT I FEEL STRONGLY ABOUT
ISSUES OF RACIAL JUSTICE AND
POVERTY IN CITIES AND I FEEL
STRONGLY THAT THERE HAS TO BE
SOMETHING DONE WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF OUR -- OF THE WAY
THIS COUNTRY IS.
AND I'M OBVIOUSLY COMMITTED TO
ALL THE VALUES SUCH AS FREEDOM
OF SPEECH AND THE THINGS THAT I
FEEL ENLIGHTENED AND SEMI
LIBERALS ARE FOR.
BRIAN: DO YOU THINK PEOPLE
WOULD BE SURPRISED THAT YOU
VOTED FOR GEORGE BUSH IN 1988?
KATHARINE: I SUPPOSE SO.
I THINK THE MOST SURPRISED
PERSON WOULD BE PRESIDENT BUSH.
BRIAN: WHY DO YOU THINK HE
WOULD BE SURPRISED?
KATHARINE: WELL, I THINK THAT
MOST PRESIDENTS GET SENSITIVE
ABOUT "THE POST" AND "NEWSWEEK"
AS WELL, AND HE HAD HIS ISSUES
WITH US BUT I THINK ANY
PRESIDENT DOES.
BUT I SUSPECT HE WOULD NOT
THINK I VOTED FOR HIM.
BRIAN: GIVE US JUST A THUMBNAIL
SKETCH OF "THE POST" COMPANY
TODAY, HOW MANY NEWSPAPERS,
TELEVISION STATIONS, HOW BIG IS
IT, WHAT IS THE GROSS REVENUES
IN A YEAR'S BASIS?
KATHARINE: WE ARE ABOUT $1.6
BILLION IN ANNUAL REVENUE.
THE COMPANY HOLDS MAINLY "THE
WASHINGTON POST" AND WE HAVE A
SMALL NEWSPAPERINGS THE EVERETT
HAROLD" AND HALF OF THE
"INTERNATIONAL HAROLD TRIBUNE"
AND THEN WE HAVE "NEWSWEEK" AND
WE HAVE SIX TELEVISION
STATIONS.
A MILLION AND A HALF CABLE
CONNECTIONS.
AND WE ALSO HAVE DIGITAL, INK,
WHICH IS OUR DIRECT -- DIGITAL,
INC., WHICH IS OUR DIGITAL
WEBSITE.
BRIAN: ARE YOU CHAIRMAN OF THE
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE?
KATHARINE: NO.
YES, I AM CHAIRMAN OF THE
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE.
BRIAN: HOW LONG WERE YOU
CHAIRMAN OF "THE WASHINGTON
POST" COMPANY?
KATHARINE: 30 YEARS.
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT AVERAGE.
BRIAN: GO BACK TO SAN
FRANCISCO.
THEN YOU COME BACK TO
WASHINGTON.
WHEN WAS YOUR FIRST JOB AT "THE
POST"?
KATHARINE: IN 19 -- WELL, I
WORKED THERE SUMMERS IN
COLLEGE.
BRIAN: AFTER SCHOOL?
KATHARINE: AFTER SCHOOL IN 1939
WHEN MY FATHER CAME OUT AND
SUGGESTED I COME BACK FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND WORK ON "THE
POST" AND I WAS -- IT WAS TIME
FOR ME TO LEAVE THERE IN MANY
WEEK" AND WE HAVE SIX
TELEVISION STATIONS.
A MILLION AND A HALF CABLE
CONNECTIONS.
AND WE ALSO HAVE DIGITAL, INK,
WHICH IS OUR DIRECT -- DIGITAL,
INC., WHICH IS OUR DIGITAL
WEBSITE.
BRIAN: ARE YOU CHAIRMAN OF THE
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE?
KATHARINE: NO.
YES, I AM CHAIRMAN OF THE
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE.
BRIAN: HOW LONG WERE YOU
CHAIRMAN OF "THE WASHINGTON
POST" COMPANY?
KATHARINE: 30 YEARS.
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT AVERAGE.
BRIAN: GO BACK TO SAN
FRANCISCO.
THEN YOU COME BACK TO
WASHINGTON.
WHEN WAS YOUR FIRST JOB AT "THE
POST"?
KATHARINE: IN 19 -- WELL, I
WORKED THERE SUMMERS IN
COLLEGE.
BRIAN: AFTER SCHOOL?
KATHARINE: AFTER SCHOOL IN 1939
WHEN MY FATH LETTERS TO THE EDI
I WROTE A FEW EDITORIALS OF NO
GREAT MOMENT.
BRIAN: WHEN DID YOU MEET PHIL
GRAMM?
KATHARINE: THAT YEAR WHEN I
CAME BACK.
I WAS REALLY SURPRISED BECAUSE
WHEN I LEFT WASHINGTON TO GO TO
COLLEGE IT WAS STILL A VERY
REPUBLICAN TOWN AND IT WAS KIND
OF STUFFY, YOU KNOW.
THERE WERE PARTIES OF MY
PARENTS' AGE AND OUR PARTIES
WERE KIND OF DANCES AND THIRD
GENERATION REAL ESTATE AND WHEN
I GOT BACK THE NEW DEAL HAD
COME AND IT WAS PREWAR.
AND THE TOWN WAS JUST FULL OF
ATTRACTIVE YOUNG MEN.
AND IT WAS NOT THE TOWN I
REMEMBERED.
I WAS SIMPLY THRILLED.
BRIAN: HOW DID YOU MEET HIM?
KATHARINE: I MET HIM IN A HOUSE
WHERE I GOT TO KNOW SOME OF THE
PEOPLE -- TWO OF THE PEOPLE WHO
WORKED ON "THE POST" THAT WERE
LIVING THERE.
THERE WERE 12 BACHELORS IN THIS
HOUSE.
AND HE WAS ONE OF THE 12.
I DIDN'T MEET HIM UNTIL HE WAS
GOING OUT WITH SOME OTHER WOMEN
-- GIRLS.
AND I ACTUALLY MET HIM ONE
NIGHT WHEN WE HAD ALL GONE TO A
RESTAURANT AND WE WERE COMING
BACK.
THEY WERE LIVING ON S STREET.
THEY HADN'T MOVED TO ARLINGTON
WHICH THEY LATER DID.
I MET HIM WITH A LOT OF OTHER
PEOPLE.
THE TAIL END OF THE PARTY WAS
COMING IN.
UNFORTUNATELY A SCREEN FELL
ONTO HIS HEAD AND HE WAS
STARTLED AND LOOKED UP AND WE
-- I LOOKED AT HIM AND IN FACT
I MET A GIRL THAT NIGHT WHEN I
WENT TO THE BATHROOM AND SHE
SAID SHE WENT TO LAW SCHOOL AND
I SAID HOW MARVELOUS.
I COULD NEVER DO THAT.
TELL ME ABOUT IT.
HOW DO YOU DO IT?
SHE SAID, WELL, I'M ENGAGED TO
PHIL  GRAHAM AND HE COMES BACK
AND PICKS ME UP AND THAT HELPS
A LOT.
I JUST SAID OH.
AND THEN HE -- THEY BROKE UP
AND HE WENT OUT WITH A FRIEND
OF MIND CALLED ALICE AND SHE
SAID, DID I KNOW PHIL?
I SAID, NO, I DIDN'T.
SHE SAID, YOU SHOULD.
HE'S JUST THE GREATEST.
I SAID OH.
AND THEN ABOUT NEW YEAR'S MY
SISTER GAVE A PARTY AND INVITED
EVERYBODY AT THE HOUSE WHERE
THEY WERE THEN LIVING AT.
THERE WERE 12 OF THEM, AND HE
WAS IN THE PARTY.
WE FIRST GOT TO KNOW EACH OTHER
THAT WAY.
AND THIS DEVELOPED RATHER
QUICKLY BECAUSE THE THIRD TIME
WE WENT OUT TOGETHER HE
DISCUSSED MARRIAGE.
BRIAN: THIRD TIME?
KATHARINE: THE THIRD TIME.
BRIAN: AND HOW MUCH LATER DID
YOU MARRY HIM?
KATHARINE: WELL, I SAID THIS
WAS A LITTLE HASTY.
I WAS REALLY INTRIGUED BY THE
IDEA BUT I SAID WE HAD TO BE
VERY DELIBERATE AND WAIT A
MONTH.
AND I THINK WE HARDLY DID WAIT
A MONTH.
AND WE WERE MARRIED THAT JUNE.
AFTER THE -- HE WAS WORKING FOR
JUSTICE -- SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE STANLEY REEN AND GOING
TO CLERK FOR JUSTICE FRANKFURT
THE NEXT YEAR SO WHEN THE COURT
ADJOURNED WE MARRIED JUNE.
BRIAN: AND BOTH JUSTICES WERE
AT THE WEDDING?
KATHARINE: THEY WERE.
BRIAN: JUSTICE FRANKFURTER WAS
HOW CLOSE TO YOU AND YOUR
HUSBAND DURING THOSE YEARS?
KATHARINE: HE WAS A MENTOR TO
PHIL WHO HAD GOTTEN TO KNOW HIM
WHEN HE WAS STILL AT THE
HARVARD LAW SCHOOL AND WHO
CHOSE THE FIRST FIVE CLERKS
FROM THE LAW SCHOOL BOYS HE
KNEW OF WHICH PHIL WAS ONE.
AND I HAD KNOW HIM BECAUSE MY
PARENTS WERE FRIENDS OF HIM
TOO.
I DIDN'T KNOW HIM WELL.
WE WERE GREAT FRIENDS.
HE WAS SIMPLY WONDERFUL TO US.
AND HE WAS SO FUNNY.
AND SO INTIMATE.
HE LIKED THE BOYS TO ARGUE WITH
HIM.
AND PARTICULARLY LAW CLERKS.
IF THEY DIDN'T AGREE WITH HIM
THEY WOULD ALL INDULGE IN
SCREAMING FIGHTS.
I WAS SHOCKED BY SOME OF THEIR
MANNERS.
HE LIKED THIS CONFRONTATION.
HE LIKED TO DISCUSS ISSUES LIKE
THAT.
AND HE WAS WONDERFUL TO ME AND
TO US AND BOTH YOU AND MRS.
FRANKFURTER WHO BECAME A FRIEND
TOO WERE VERY, VERY CLOSE TO
US.
BRIAN: HOW MANY CHILDREN DID
YOU AND PHIL  GRAHAM HAVE?
KATHARINE: WE HAD FOUR.
I HAVE FOUR.
MY OLDEST IS ELIZABETH WHO IS A
JOURNALIST AND WRITES FOR "THE
POST" ON FOREIGN AFFAIRS.
BRIAN: KNOWN AS LALLY.
KATHARINE: DONALD, EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE COMPANY.
WILLIAM CALLED BILL, WHO HAS AN
INVESTMENT PARTNERSHIP IN LOS
ANGELES BUT WHO LIVES ON THE
VINEYARD IN THE SUMMER AND VERY
INTERESTED AND LOVES THE
VINEYARD AND LIVES NEXT DOOR
WITH HIS CHILDREN WHICH I LOVE
THAT.
STEVEN WHICH IS MARRIED AND
LIVES IN NEW YORK AND GETTING A
POSTGRADUATE DEGREE IN
LITERATURE AND IS -- IN
TEACHING BUT HE HAS BEEN IN THE
THEATER AND HAS PRODUCED AND
HAS AN EXPERIMENTAL THEATER
GOING.
BRIAN: YOU LOST A SON, THOUGH?
KATHARINE: I LOST OUR FIRST
BABY WHICH WAS TREMENDOUSLY
TRAUMATIC WHO WAS BORN FULL
TERM BUT BECAUSE IT WAS IN
WASHINGTON DURING -- AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE WAR, HOSPITALS
WERE VERY BUSY, AND IT WAS --
IT WAS AN ACCIDENTAL THING IN
THE HOSPITAL.
IT REALLY SHOULDN'T HAVE
HAPPENED.
AND PHIL WENT IN THE ARMY RIGHT
AFTERWARDS SO IT WAS PRETTY
DEVASTATING, YES.
BRIAN: WHAT IMPACT DID IT HAVE
ON YOU?
DO YOU REMEMBER?
KATHARINE: WELL, IT WAS JUST
AWFUL BECAUSE I THOUGHT PHIL
WAS GOING IN THE ARMY, IT WAS
THE END OF EVERYTHING.
WE'D NEVER HAVE ANY CHILDREN.
SOMETHING MIGHT HAPPEN TO HIM.
IT WAS A PRETTY AWFUL MOMENT.
BRIAN: HOW LONG DID YOU -- HOW
LONG PHILGRAHAM SPEND IN THE
ARMY?
KATHARINE: WELL, HE WENT IN --
IT WAS 22 1/2 YEARS, I THINK.
BRIAN: WHEN DID HE GO TO WORK
FOR "THE POST"?
KATHARINE: MY FATHER TALKED TO
HIM WHILE HE WAS IN OFFICERS
SCHOOL.
HE HAD BY THIS TIME INVESTED
HEAVILY OF BOTH FINANCIAL
RESOURCES AND ENERGY AND EFFORT
IN BUILDING UP "THE POST" AND
IT WAS VERY DISCOURAGING
BECAUSE THEY WERE LOSING MONEY
EVERY YEAR AND HE WAS MAKING
PROGRESS OF GREAT KINDS, BOTH
IN CIRCULATION AND TO SOME
EXTENT IN ADVERTISING BUT IT
WAS TERRIBLY DISCOURAGING.
HE WANTED TO MAKE SURE HE HAD A
SUCCESSOR IN PLACE SO THERE WAS
A POINT TO ALL THIS WORK.
MY BROTHER BY THEN WAS A
PSYCHIATRIST AND INTERESTED IN
MEDICINE AND SO HE ASKED PHIL
IF HE'D BE INTERESTED.
WE HAD LONG TALKS ABOUT THIS
AND I SAID HE HAS TO DECIDE AND
HE DID FINALLY AND HE SAID WHAT
DID I THINK.
I LOVED WASHINGTON BUT I WAS
WILLING -- HE WANTED TO GO INTO
LAW AND POLITICS IN FLORIDA.
BRIAN: IS THAT -- HIS BROTHER
WAS SENATOR BOB GRAHAM?
KATHARINE: AND PHIL KIND OF
ASPIRED TO WHAT HIS BROTHER
WAS.
I THINK HE'S A GREAT AND VERY
FINE SENATOR.
BRIAN: HOW MANY YEARS WAS PHIL
GRAHAM PUBLISHER?
KATHARINE: 17.
AND DURING THAT TIME HE BECAME
PUBLISHER WHEN HE WAS NOT QUITE
31 BECAUSE MY FATHER -- HE WENT
ON "THE POST" RIGHT AFTER HE
GOT BACK AND WE HAD TERMINAL
LEAVE.
IT WAS JANUARY, 1946.
AND SIX MONTHS LATER MY FATHER
WAS OFFERED TO BE PRESIDENT OF
THE WORLD BANK BY PRESIDENT
TRUMAN AND HE SAID TO PHIL, I
WON'T LEAVE IF YOU DON'T WANT
ME TO BUT THIS IS KIND OF MY
FIRST LOVE BECAUSE THAT WAS THE
KIND OF THING HE HAD DONE FOR
THE GOVERNMENT AND HE THOUGHT
SOMEBODY OUGHT TO START THE
WORLD BANK.
AND PHIL SAID, NO, THAT'S ALL
RIGHT.
HE SHOULD DO WHATEVER HE WANTED
TO DO.
SO MY FATHER DID THAT AND NAMED
PHIL PUBLISHER.
SO HE TOOK UP THE STRUGGLE AND
FROM 1947 TO 1954 HE, TOO, HAD
THE SAME KIND OF TIME, REALLY,
REALLY DIFFICULT TIME.
AND IN 1954 MY FATHER, WHO HAD
COME BACK FROM THE WORLD BANK
WHERE THE -- SIX MONTHS AFTER
HE WENT BECAUSE HE DID GET IT
STARTED AND HE DID GET THE
REGULATIONS CHANGED THAT MADE
HIM REALLY FRUSTRATED.
AND HE FELT HE COULDN'T DO ANY
MORE THAN HE'D DONE FATHER
TALKED TO HIM WHILE HE WAS IN
OFFICERS SCHOOL.
HE HAD BY THIS TIME INVESTED
HEAVILY OF BOTH FINANCIAL
RESOURCES AND ENERGY AND EFFORT
IN BUILDING UP "THE POST" AND
IT WAS VERY DISCOURAGING
BECAUSE THEY WERE LOSING MONEY
EVERY YEAR AND HE WAS MAKING
PROGRESS OF GREAT KINDS, BOTH
IN CIRCULATION AND TO SOME
EXTENT IN ADVERTISING BUT IT
WAS TERRIBLY DISCOURAGING.
HE WANTED TO MAKE SURE HE HAD A
SUCCESSOR IN PLACE SO THERE WAS
A POINT TO ALL THIS WORK.
MY BROTHER BY THEN WAS A
PSYCHIATRIST AND INTERESTED IN
MEDICINE AND SO HE ASKED PHIL
IF HE'D BE INTERESTED.
WE HAD LONG TALKS ABOUT THIS
AND I SAID HE HAS TO DECIDE AND
HE DID FINALLY AND HE SAID WHAT
DID I THINK.
I LOVED WASHINGTON BUT I WAS
WAS.
I THINK HE'S A  C
FIRST LOVE BECAUSE THAT WAS THE
COME BACK FROM THE WORLD BANK
WAS AT THE WORLD BANK.
KATHARINE: HE LEFT IT TO THE
BANK BECAUSE IT WAS HUGE AND
CUMBERSOME AND HE LEFT IT
THERE.
BOB INHERITED IT.
I BELIEVE TOOK IT WITH HIM TO
HIS OWN OFFICE?
BRIAN: TO HIS OWN OFFICE, YES.
I BRING THIS UP BECAUSE YOU ARE
CLOSE FRIENDS WITH BOB TODAY?
KATHARINE: I AM.
HE'S A GOOD FRIEND.
BRIAN: DID HE SERVE ON THE
BOARD EVENTUALLY?
KATHARINE: YES, HE DID.
YES, HE DID.
BRIAN: YOU DEVOTE A LOT OF TIME
TO YOUR HUSBAND, DECEASED
HUSBAND.
HAD THE STORY ABOUT HIS DEATH
BEEN TOLD IN THE DETAIL THAT
YOU TOLD IT?
KATHARINE: NO COHERENTLY -- NOT
CONSECUTIVELY.
I THINK MOST OF WHAT I TOLD HAD
BEEN HERE AND THERE.
BRIAN: HAD YOU -- WAS IT HARD
TO RETELL THAT STORY, RETHINK
IT, RELIVE IT?
KATHARINE: IT WASN'T EASY, NOT
ONLY BECAUSE OF THE SENSITIVITY
OF WHAT I WAS WRITING BUT
BECAUSE I WANTED TO BE SURE TO
PUT IT IN CONTEXT.
IT WAS A COMPARATIVELY SHORT
PERIOD IN WHICH HE WAS FINELY
-- DID SOME QUITE ABERRATIONAL
THINGS.
AND -- BUT MOST OF OUR LIFE
TOGETHER WAS WONDERFUL AND HE
WAS WONDERFUL AND I DIDN'T WANT
THE BAD PART AT THE END TO
OVERSHADOW THE VERY, VERY GOOD
PART.
I WANTED TO TELL -- ONE OF THE
REASONS I WROTE THIS BOOK WAS
TO SAY HOW GREAT HE WAS AND MY
PARENTS WERE EACH IN THEIR OWN
WAY.
I THOUGHT THERE WERE THREE
PEOPLE THAT DESERVED TO BE
REMEMBERED AND TO BE WRITTEN
ABOUT.
BRIAN: WHAT WERE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF HIS DEATH?
KATHARINE: HE WAS SUBJECT TO
MANIC DEPRESSIVE ILLNESS BEFORE
LITHIUM -- I THINK IT WAS BEING
EXPERIMENTED WITH BUT CERTAINLY
WASN'T BEING USED.
AND HE WENT TO A PSYCHIATRIST
WHO DIDN'T BELIEVE IN DRUGS OF
ANY KIND OR ELECTRIC SHOCK OR
ANYTHING.
AND SO PHIL HIMSELF DIDN'T --
BECAUSE OF THE PSYCHIATRIST,
BECAUSE HE THOUGHT IT LEFT YOU
NOT AS -- AS HUMAN AS HE HAD
BEEN, THAT IT AFFECTED YOUR
MIND.
SO HE DIDN'T WANT -- I DON'T
THINK THEY -- ANYTHING WAS
AVAILABLE.
HE DIDN'T WANT IT EITHERLY.
HE SUFFERED FROM UNTREATED
MANIC DEPRESSION.
AT THE END HE WENT OFF WITH A
YOUNG WOMAN, A RESEARCHER AT
"NEWSWEEK" WHOM HE MET AND VERY
QUICKLY PICKED UP AND TOOK UP
WITH AND IT WAS FINALLY AFTER
SOME HESITATIONS AND BACKS AND
FORTH HE LEFT WITH HER AND SAID
WHAT THE MATTER WITH HIM WAS ME
AND HE WANTED A DIVORCE AND HE
WAS GOING TO KEEP THE PAPER.
AND HE WAS GOING TO MARRY HER.
AND THEN AS I KIND OF THOUGHT
MIGHT HAPPEN, BECAUSE THIS WAS
PRETTY SPECTACULAR, AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE, IN 1962 --
BRIAN: WAS IT PUBLIC?
KATHARINE: YES.
IT HAD TO BE.
IT WASN'T AT FIRST.
BUT WE HAD SUCCESSFULLY HIDDEN
HIS ILLNESS WHICH HAD STARTED
GETTING SERIOUS IN 1957 AND
FROM THEN THE CYCLES WERE
GETTING CLOSER AND WORSE.
BUT PEOPLE DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT
UNTIL THIS VERY PUBLIC EVENT
HAPPENED.
SO THEY THOUGHT, WELL, THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENS SOMETIMES.
I EVEN SAID TO ONE FRIEND, YOU
KNOW HE'S ILL.
SHE SAID, DON'T SAY THAT.
EVERYBODY SAYS THAT WHEN THEIR
HUSBAND LEAVES THEM.
SO I REALIZED THAT I BETTER NOT
SAY THAT BUT I KNEW THIS WAS
PART OF IT.
AND HE GOT DEPRESSED IN THE
SUMMER OF THAT YEAR IN JULY.
AND --
BRIAN: 1962.
KATHARINE: 1963.
BRIAN: JACK KENNEDY WAS KILLED
IN NOVEMBER AND YOU WERE ALL
CLOSE.
KATHARINE: THEY WERE FRIENDS.
PHIL KNEW THE PRESIDENT PRETTY
WELL AND I KNEW OF HIM TOO AND
WE DID SEE SOMETHING OF HIM.
AND HE WAS ALSO GOOD FRIENDS
WITH THE VICE PRESIDENT.
AND SO HE CAME HOME AND ASKED
THE GIRL TO GO BACK HOME AND HE
CAME BACK TO US BUT HE WAS SO
ILL AND SO DEPRESSED AND I HAD
SEEN HIM THROUGH TWO OF THESE
DEPRESSIONS.
I JUST FELT UNEQUAL TO DOING IT
AGAIN.
HE WAS ASKED TO INVOLUNTARILY
GO TO A HOSPITAL FOR WHICH HE
SUCCEEDED IN GETTING A DAY OFF
WHICH HE DID AND KILLED
HIMSELF.
BRIAN: YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR LIFE
TOGETHER AND ALL THE PEOPLE YOU
KNEW.
I GUESS IT WAS THE MOMENT IN
THE EISENHOWER ADMINISTRATION
WHERE YOUR HUSBAND WAS ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT.
AND THE INFLUENCING OF THE
ARKANSAS SITUATION, CENTRAL
HIGH SCHOOL?
KATHARINE: HE HAD GOTTEN
INVOLVED A LITTLE BIT.
I THINK HE WAS VERY -- HE FELT
VERY SOUTHERN AND HE WAS VERY
INVOLVED IN CIVIL RIGHTS AND
CIVIL LIBERTIES AND ACTUALLY IN
1957 HE HAD BECOME INVOLVED
WITH THEN-MAJORITY LEADER
LYNDON JOHNSON IN PASSING THE
1957 CIVIL RIGHTS LAW.
HE HAD VERY MUCH HELPED HIM GET
THAT LAW PASSED BY TALKING TO
JOE RALL AND THE NAACP AND BY
TELLING THEM -- THERE WERE NO
VOTING RIGHTS ACT AND IT WAS --
THERE WERE VOTING RIGHTS AND
NOT SCHOOL DESEGREGATION.
AND THERE WAS A JURY
REGULATION.
YOU COULD APPEAL TO A JURY
WHICH AT THAT TIME WERE LARGELY
WHITE.
IT WAS A WEAK CIVIL RIGHTS LAW
BUT IT WAS THE FIRST ONE IN
ABOUT 84 YEARS.
AND PERSUADED JOE AND THE NAACP
TO ACCEPT THIS AND THAT'S THE
WAY IT GOT PASSED.
BRIAN: HE ALSO WAS FIRST
CHAIRMAN OF COMSACK?
KATHARINE: YES.
DURING -- ACTUALLY DURING THE
EISENHOWER PERIOD WHICH YOU
REFERRED TO, HE HAD BECOME
INVOLVED IN THE DESEGREGATION
OF THE LITTLE ROCK SCHOOL AND
HE WANTED TO PREVENT EISENHOWER
SENDING THE TROOPS IN THERE.
AND HE WORKED VERY HARD AND
SOMEWHAT FRATICALLY TO TRY TO
GET EVERYBODY TOGETHER AND GET
THE SCHOOL DESEGREGATED.
AND WHEN IT FAILED, WHICH WAS
GOING TO BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR
WAS STANDING AGAINST THE SCHOOL
DESEGREGATION, I THINK IT THREW
HIM INTO HIS FIRST DEPRESSION
IN 1957, ACTUALLY.
BRIAN: THE REASON I MENTIONED
THE COM SLS SACK THING, HOW DO
YOU THINK PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA
OUGHT TO BE INVOLVED?
KATHARINE: HE WAS HEAD OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS SATELLITE,
INCORPORATED.
BRIAN: RIGHT.
KATHARINE: HE WAS HEAD OF THAT.
KATHARINE: HALF GOVERNMENT,
HALF --
BRIAN: HALF GOVERNMENT, HALF
PRIVATE.
KATHARINE: AND YET MAINTAINED
HIS ROLE AS PUBLISHER.
I DON'T THINK IT'S SOMETHING
PEOPLE WOULD DREAM OF DOING
THESE DAYS.
BEFORE THAT HE WAS HEAVILY
INVOLVED IN POLITICS.
INVOLVED WITH LYNDON JOHNSON.
INVOLVED, AS YOU SAID, WITH
LITTLE ROCK.
AND INVOLVED ACTUALLY -- I TELL
A STORY ABOUT DESEGREGATION OF
THE SWIMMING POOLS IN
WASHINGTON WHICH HE KEPT A
STORY OUT OF THE PAPER AND MADE
A DEAL WITH THIS INTERIOR
DEPARTMENT THAT IF HE ACQUIRED
A STORY OF A RIOT HAD BEEN
TAKING PLACE ABOUT SWIMMING
POOLS THEY WOULD DESEGREGATE
THEM.
THAT WAS USING THE PAPER AND
INFLUENCING THE NEWS.
I THINK THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE
THESE DAYS.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO INFLUENCE
EVENTS BY TELLING -- GIVING
PEOPLE INFORMATION BY WHICH
THEY CAN MAKE DECISIONS.
AND SO I THINK IT WOULDN'T
HAPPEN TODAY.
BRIAN: YOU WROTE ON PAGE 140,
IT WASN'T UNTIL YEARS LATER I
LOOKED AT THE DOWNSIDE OF ALL
THIS AND REALIZED PERVERSELY I
HAD SEEM TO ENJOY THE ROLE OF
DORMANT WIFE.
FOR WHATEVER REASON I LIKED TO
BE DOMINATED AND BE THE
IMPLEMENTOR.
KATHARINE: I MEANT THE WAY IT
WAS WRITTEN.
I DIDN'T FEEL PUT UPON.
I ADORED OUR LIFE.
I LIKED BEING WHAT I CALL THE
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER.
I DID EVERYTHING AT HOME.
I KEPT THE HOUSES RUNNING.
I TOOK CARE OF THE CHILDREN.
I MADE THE DECISIONS ABOUT
SUMMERS.
I BOUGHT AND SOLD HOUSES AND
MOVED.
I DID EVERYTHING THAT MOST
FAMILIES I THINK SHARE BECAUSE
HE WAS SO -- WORKING SO HARD
AND I WAS TRYING TO TAKE THE
PRESSURE OFF BY DOING
EVERYTHING AT HOME.
I WAS INTERESTED IN OUR LIFE.
I WAS INTERESTED IN MEETING THE
PEOPLE WE MET.
I ADORED THE FAMILY.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I SAW MYSELF
THE WAY PEOPLE WOULD VIEW THAT
SITUATION NOW IN WHICH YOU WERE
BROUGHT UP TO THINK MEN WERE
INTELLECTUALLY SUPERIOR AND YOU
KIND OF LIVE INTELLECTUALLY
AWESOME WHICH IS OF COURSE
RIDICULOUS.
EVEN -- YOU CAN WORK OR NOT
WORK THESE DAYS.
WOMEN HAVE CHOICES, THAT'S THE
MAIN POINT.
BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE YOUR OWN
IDENTITY AND YOUR OWN
INTERESTS.
BRIAN: YOU POINT OUT IN THE
BOOK THAT HE'S BURIED LITERALLY
RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET FROM
WHERE YOU LIVE.
KATHARINE: THAT'S TRUE.
BRIAN: HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
KATHARINE: IN A REALLY WEIRD
WAY BECAUSE THE CEMETERY IS A
PERFECTLY BEAUTIFUL CEMETERY
ACROSS THE STREET, OAK HILL.
AND THERE WEREN'T MANY PLACES.
AND IT'S AN OLD CEMETERY.
HE GOT KIND OF INTERESTED IN
HAVING A PLOT THERE FOR US.
IT WAS KIND OF LIKE GETTING
INTO A CLUB OR SOMETHING.
OUR GREAT FRIEND, THE BRUCES,
AND PEOPLE WE KNEW HAD THESE
PLOTS THERE AND HE MADE JOKES
ABOUT THIS AND SAID WE SHOULD
BE SANDWICHED IN THERE
SOMEWHERE.
ONE DAY HE CAME HOME FROM A
SCHOOL MEETING AND SAID, WELL,
I GOT THIS PLOT BECAUSE I'VE
BECOME ACQUAINTED WITH SOMEBODY
ON THE SCHOOL BOARD AND WE CAN
GET IN.
IT BECAME A FAMILY KIND OF
JOKE.
AND HE EVEN MADE JOKES ABOUT,
YOU CAN JUST WHEEL ME ACROSS
THE STREET.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, WITH WHAT
HAPPENED, OF COURSE, IT'S
APPALLING.
YOU NEVER THOUGHT OF IT AS A
REALITY.
AND SO WE WERE AT THE CHURCH,
AT THE FUNERAL, AND MY -- ONE
OF MY SONS AND OTHER PEOPLE
MADE THE ARRANGEMENTS SO I HAD
NO IDEA THAT THIS PLOT WAS
LITERALLY ACROSS THE STREET
FROM THE HOUSE IN FRONT OF THE
LITTLE CHAPEL.
AND I WAS PRETTY STARTLED WHEN
WE ARRIVED THERE AFTER THE
SERVICE TO FIND IT WAS RIGHT
THERE IN FRONT OF MY EYES.
AND FIRST IT BOTHERED ME BUT
NOW I REALLY LIKE IT.
BRIAN: AND YOU LIVED IN THAT
HOUSE FOR THE LAST 34 YEARS?
KATHARINE: 50.
BRIAN: AND YOU NEVER REMARRIED.
KATHARINE: NO.
BRIAN: BUT WE LEARN IN THE BOOK
YOU HAD SOME SUITORS LIKE
STEVENS AT ONE POINT?
KATHARINE: WELL, I HAD FRIENDS,
PUT IT THAT WAY.
BRIAN: HAS IT BEEN HARD TO BE
IN A JOB LIKE YOURS AND RESIST
THE -- YOU KNOW, ATTENTION YOU
WOULD GET FROM MEN?
KATHARINE: ACTUALLY, NO.
BECAUSE I REALLY WORKED
TERRIBLY HARD AND I MOVED
AROUND WHERE I HAD TO AND I
LIVED A LIFE THAT WAS REALLY
ESSENTIALLY WORK EVEN IF I WENT
OUT IN THE EVENING, IT WAS
EITHER SOMETHING I HAD TO DO OR
REALLY DID WANT TO DO OR I
STAYED HOME.
AND I DON'T THINK THERE WAS
ROOM IN THAT LIFE TO GET
MARRIED TO ANYBODY THAT WAS
VERY STRONG AND WANTED ME TO BE
THERE MORE THAN I WAS.
SO IT REALLY NEVER CAME UP AS A
PRACTICAL FACT.
BRIAN: AFTER YOUR HUSBAND SHOT
HIMSELF, HOW LONG WAS IT BEFORE
YOU TOOK OVER "THE POST"?
KATHARINE: I WENT AWAY FOR A
MONTH AND CAME BACK AND WENT TO
WORK BUT THAT WASN'T TO SAY I
TOOK OVER "THE POST."
I WENT TO WORK TO LEARN THE
ISSUES.
I DIDN'T REALLY SEE MYSELF AS
TAKING OVER "THE POST," BUT I
DID GO TO WORK RIGHT AWAY AND
GRADUALLY I LEARNED YOU
COULDN'T SIT THERE SHUNNING THE
THING AND I WAS ENCOURAGED TO
BY SOME OF THE EXECUTIVES AND
MAINLY BY FREDRIC WHOM PHIL
MADE THE CHAIRMAN WHO HAD BEEN
OUR CORPORATE LAWYER.
AND HE SAID, YOU HAVE TO COME
TO WORK.
AND I WAS HAPPY TO DO THAT
BECAUSE I CARED A GREAT DEAL
ABOUT THE COMPANY AND ABOUT
"THE POST" WHICH I LIVED,
STRUGGLED FOR ITS EXISTENCE.
IT HAD BEEN PART OF MY WHOLE
LIFE AND I KNEW WHAT HAD GONE
INTO MAKING IT AS SUCCESSFUL AS
IT EVEN WAS WHICH WAS STILL
COMPETITIVE.
AND SO GRADUALLY HAVING GONE TO
WORK TO LEARN, I WORKED WITH
HIM AND WORKED AS PRESIDENT OF
THE COMPANY.
AND I BECAME PUBLISHER WHEN
JOHN, WHO HAD BEEN PUBLISHER --
MADE PUBLISHER WHEN PHIL LEFT
AND THEN FITZ DIED 10 YEARS
LATER JUST AFTER WE HAD GONE
PUBLIC AND SO THEN I BECAME --
THEN I DID TAKE OVER THE
COMPANY.
BRIAN: YOU CALL 1971 AND 1976
THE TURBULENT YEARS.
WHY?
KATHARINE: WELL, BECAUSE
RAPIDLY WE WENT THROUGH THE
PENTAGON PAPERS AND WATERGATE
AND JUST AS I THOUGHT THINGS
HAD CALMED DOWN WE WENT THROUGH
A VERY VIOLENT PRESSMAN STRIKE
IN 1975.
SO THOSE WERE THREE REALLY
COSMIC EVENTS THAT HAPPENED AND
IN PUBLIC, SO TO SPEAK.
BRIAN: THE PENTAGON PAPERS
CHAPTER WHEN YOU READ -- I
WROTE SOME NAMES DOWN THE BACK
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY
PEOPLE THAT PEOPLE HEARD THAT
WERE INVOLVED AT ONE TIME.
I WANTED TO SEE IF YOU CAN
EXPLAIN IT.
PEOPLE HAD BEEN IN THE
GOVERNMENT AND OUT AND LAW
FIRMS AND OUT.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW HOW YOU
KEPT ALL THESE PEOPLE STRAIGHT.
FOR INSTANCE, YOU HAD YOUR
LAWYER AT ONE TIME WAS BILL
ROGERS WHO HAD BECOME SECRETARY
OF STATE DURING THE TIME OF THE
PENTAGON PAPERS.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU --
KATHARINE: NO.
BRIAN: HE WASN'T YOUR LAWYER
THEN BUT SECRETARY OF STATE BUT
HAD BEEN YOUR LAWYER?
KATHARINE: YES, RIGHT.
BRIAN: PAUL, WAS HE PRESIDENT
OF YOUR COMPANY?
KATHARINE: YES.
BRIAN: HE HAD BEEN SECRETARY OF
THE NAVY.
KATHARINE: YES.
BRIAN: KILPATRICK PLAYED A ROLE
IN YOUR COMPANY.
KATHARINE: HE WAS INVOLVED WITH
US AS A LAW PARTNER.
AND BEFORE THAT HE'D BEEN IN
THE GOVERNMENT.
BRIAN: WAS HE DEPUTY --
KATHARINE: YES.
HE WAS DEPUTY DEFENSE
SECRETARY.
BRIAN: AND ED WILLIAMS HAD BEEN
YOUR HUSBAND'S ATTORNEY.
KATHARINE: WHEN HE WAS -- WHEN
HE WAS THINKING HE WANTED TO
DIVORCE.
BRIAN: DIVORCE AND TAKE SOME OF
YOUR MONEY AND GO THE OTHER
WAY.
AND YOU ENDED UP LEANING ON HIM
AT A TIME.
KATHARINE: WE BECAME VERY CLOSE
FRIENDS AND THEN HE CAME IN AS
A LAWYER LATER.
ACTUALLY WITH FITZ AND I
BROUGHT HIM IN TOGETHER.
BRIAN: AND BOB MCNAMARA WAS AT
SCOTTIE'S HOME THE NIGHT THE
PENTAGON PAPERS WAS PUBLISHED
IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND
ASKED HIM ADVICE.
IN ADDITION TO THAT, SCOTTIE
WAS A VERY CLOSE FRIEND OF
YOURS WHO RAN "THE NEW YORK
TIMES," WASHINGTON BUREAU,
TRIED TO GET TO WORK FOR YOU.
AND YOUR NATIONAL EDITOR WHO
YOU WENT ON TO NOT THINK SO
HIGHLY OF IN YOUR BOOK, AS I
REMEMBER, CRITICAL OF "THE
POST"?
KATHARINE: NO.
BRIAN: ANYWAY -- HOW DO YOU
DEAL IN A TOWN LIKE THIS WHEN
ONE DAY SOMEBODY'S YOUR LAWYER
AND NEXT DAY IN THE GOVERNMENT
AND YOU STAY PAT BUT EVERYBODY
ELSE IS MOVING AROUND, DO YOU
EVER GET CONFUSED?
KATHARINE: NO, BECAUSE ONCE
PEOPLE ARE IN THE GOVERNMENT,
THE RELATIONSHIP CHANGES.
YOU CAN BE FRIENDS WITH PEOPLE
IN THE GOVERNMENT BUT YOU HAVE
-- THEY REMEMBER AND YOU
REMEMBER THE PAPER COMES FIRST.
SOMETIMES THE PAPER ATTACKS
YOUR FRIENDS OR DOES THINGS
EVEN THAT YOU THINK ARE UNFAIR
TO YOUR FRIENDS.
AND SOMETIMES YOU CAN REASON
WITH THE OTHERS BUT MOSTLY YOU
HAVE TO JUST STAND BY THEM.
BRIAN: WHEN YOU TRAVEL AND AS
YOU GO AROUND TALKING TO PEOPLE
ON THE BOOK TOUR AND YOU LIVED
IN SIOUX FALLS, YOU LIVED IN
CHICAGO, YOU LIVED IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
WHERE ELSE?
ANY OTHER CITIES FOR VERY LONG?
KATHARINE: NOT MUCH.
IT'S MOSTLY WASHINGTON FOR MOST
OF THE TIME.
BRIAN: WHAT I'M GETTING AT,
PEOPLE LOOK AT "THE POST" AND
THEY LOOK AT WASHINGTON,
THEY'RE CYNICAL ABOUT ALL THE
POWER AND CONTROL AND HOW DO
YOU -- HOW DO YOU TELL THEM
ABOUT THE FOLKS THAT ARE AWAY
FROM HERE SAYING YOU DON'T HAVE
TOO MUCH POWER?
KATHARINE: I TRY TO EXPLAIN
WHAT THE POWER OF A NEWSPAPER
OR MAGAZINE OR A TELEVISION
STATION ARE.
FOR INSTANCE, "THE POST" HAS
THE POWER TO INFORM PEOPLE.
AND WHERE THEY PLAY A STORY
MATTERS PROBABLY IF THEY COVER
IT WELL, IT MATTERS, BECAUSE
YOU'RE TALKING TO THE
GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE THE POWER --
SOMETIMES PEOPLE THINK YOU RUN
DOWNSTAIRS AND TALK TO EDITORS.
YOU DON'T.
I MEAN, ABOUT A STORY.
YOU NEVER SEE STORIES BEFORE
THEY GET IN THE PAPERS.
YOU HAVE THE POWER TO PICK AN
EDITOR YOU THINK OR A PUBLISHER
OR WHATEVER IT IS THAT WILL DO
THE JOB WELL AND IS IN YOUR
GENERAL MOLD OF THOUGHT BUT
AFTER THAT THEY REALLY HAVE
AUTONOMY.
AND SO YOU DON'T HAVE THE POWER
TO -- THAT PEOPLE ENVISION YOU
AS HAVING OF MAKING OR BREAKING
PEOPLE OR INFLUENCING EVENTS
DIRECTLY.
YOU HAVE MORE -- IT SOUNDS LIKE
GOODY TO SHOES THAT YOU HAVE
MORE RESPONSIBILITY THAN POWER.
BRIAN: YOU WROTE ON PAGE 360.
YOU SAY NEWS COLUMNS HAD TO BE
FAIR AND DETACHED AFTER
RECOGNIZING THERE IS REALLY NO
SUCH THING AS OBJECTIVITY.
KATHARINE: DETACHED IS A WORD
THAT'S BETTER BECAUSE
OBJECTIVITY IN THE WAY PEOPLE
INTERPRET YOU CAN HAVE.
YOU EXERCISE -- AN EDITOR
EXERCISING A JUDGMENT WHEN YOU
THINK JUST WHAT IS RELEVANT,
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SELECTIONS
WHAT GOES INTO THE PAPER AND
WHAT DOESN'T SO THAT'S WHAT I
MEAN BY THERE'S NO SUCH THING
AS OBJECTIVITY BECAUSE THE
HUMAN BEING DOES THAT.
AND YOU DO IT THE BEST YOU CAN
TO BE FAIR AND DETACHED AND
ACCURATE.
BUT YOU ARE MAKING A HUMAN
JUDGMENT.
THERE IS A PERSON MAKING IT.
THAT'S ALL I MEAN.
BRIAN: I WANTED TO -- DO YOU
REMEMBER WHO THE FIRST PERSON
YOU PERSONALLY HAD TO FIRE?
AND WHAT THE EXPERIENCE WAS
LIKE?
KATHARINE: I DO BUT I DON'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT.
BRIAN: YOU TALK ABOUT A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
I MEAN --
KATHARINE: I TALK ABOUT IT IN
THE BOOK BUT HE WAS A DEAR
FRIEND AND IT WAS VERY PAINFUL.
BRIAN: PHIL?
KATHARINE: NO.
AL FRIENDLY.
BRIAN: IS AL FRIENDLY'S
GRANDSON WORKING FOR BILL
CLINTON?
KATHARINE: YES, ANDREW.
BRIAN: HE'S WITH HIM ALL THE
TIME.
KATHARINE: YES.
BRIAN: IS IT PETER -- IS IT
DEROE?
KATHARINE: YES.
BRIAN: HELPLESSLY INADEQUATE
LEADER AND HE HAD LITTLE CHOICE
BUT TO LEAVE FOR THE DYNAMIC
CBS.
HE TOUCHED A RAW SENSITIVITY
WHEN HE ASSAULTED ME FOR NOT
BEING A PROFESSIONAL MANAGER
AND I MUST CONFESS I WEPT ON
AND OFF FOR AT LEAST TWO DAYS.
KATHARINE: HORRIFYING BUT TRUE.
BRIAN: WHY DID YOU ADMIT ALL
THIS AND WHAT WAS THE
CIRCUMSTANCE?
KATHARINE: I REALLY DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE I SHOULDN'T HAVE.
BUT I TEND TO BE UPFRONT AND
HONEST SO I GUESS I JUST TOLD
IT THE WAY IT HAPPENED.
BRIAN: HE WAS -- WHEN WAS PETER
DEROE THERE WITH YOU AND WHAT
JOB DID HE HAVE?
KATHARINE: HE WAS -- I FORE
GOAT HIS ACTUAL TITLE.
-- I FORGET HIS ACTUAL TITLE.
FIRST, HE WAS NUMBER TWO
BUSINESS PERSON AT "NEWSWEEK."
THEN ACTUALLY AFTER THAT
INCREDIBLE SCENE HE CAME BACK
FROM CBS AND RAN THE BUSINESS
SIDE OF "NEWSWEEK."
BRIAN: AND HE ACTUALLY TOLD YOU
TO YOUR FACE THAT HE THOUGHT
YOU WERE DOING A LOUSY JOB?
KATHARINE: YEP.
BRIAN: THEN YOU GO ON ABOUT 20
PAGES LATER.
ANXIETIES DURING THIS DIFFICULT
PERIOD PETER TOLD ME HE FOUND
ANOTHER JOB.
HE LEFT YOU AND TOLD YOU HE
DIDN'T LIKE WHAT YOU DID AND
YOU BROUGHT HIM BACK?
KATHARINE: YES.
BRIAN: WHY?
KATHARINE: I CAN'T ANSWER THAT.
I DON'T KNOW.
BRIAN: LATER, HE WAS --
KATHARINE: IT SEEMED LIKE THE
THING TO DO AT THE TIME.
IT WASN'T A GOOD IDEA.
BRIAN: THEN HE WENT BACK TO CBS
AND CAME TO YOU AGAIN AND HAD A
CHAT.
HE WAS QUITE WILLING TO START
WHAT WAS WRONG WITH ME AND THE
COMPANY.
BY THIS TIME I HAD GROWN
TOUGHER AND SAID ONCE WAS
ENOUGH.
IT SEEMED TO IRRITATE HIM TO
NOT REPEAT THE MONOLOGUE ON MY
FAILINGS.
WHAT TOUGHENED YOU UP?
KATHARINE: EXPERIENCE.
BRIAN: TO WHAT PURPOSE DID YOU
PUT THAT TO ONCE YOU TOUGHENED
UP?
KATHARINE: WELL, I THINK I
COULD MAKE DECISIONS BETTER AND
MORE FIRMLY.
AND STICK BY THEM AND NOT QUITE
ASK SO MUCH ADVICE.
BRIAN: YOU SAY WHEN YOU --
KATHARINE: ALTHOUGH I THINK YOU
ALWAYS ASK SOME ADVICE.
BRIAN: YOU SAY WHEN YOU FIRST
GOT TO "THE POST" IN CHARGE
THAT YOU WERE PETRIFIED ABOUT
SPEAKING.
KATHARINE: COULDN'T OPEN MY
MOUTH.
I HAD TO PRACTICE IN FRONT OF
THE CHILDREN THE FIRST YEAR I
WAS WORKING AT THE PAPER.
I WAS ASKED TO GO DOWN AND SAY
MERRY CHRISTMAS AT THE COMPANY
LUNCH AND I LITERALLY -- MY
CHILDREN ARE HILARIOUS.
THEY KEEP TELLING THIS STORY.
I PRACTICED MAKING THE SPEECH
SAYING MERRY CHRISTMAS IN FRONT
OF THE CHILDREN BECAUSE I NEVER
SAID ANYTHING IN PUBLIC TO EVEN
MY CHILDREN LINED UP IN A ROW.
BRIAN: WHAT MOMENT DO YOU
REMEMBER WHERE YOU HAD TO MAKE
THE MOST IMPORTANT SPEECH?
KATHARINE: WELL, I MADE A LOT
OF SPEECHES DEFENDING US DURING
WATERGATE.
THAT'S WHEN I STARTED SPEAKING
THE MOST.
AND I WAS TRYING TO EXPLAIN
THAT WE WERE REPORTING A STORY
AND THAT WE WEREN'T AFTER THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THAT WE
WEREN'T -- IT WASN'T OUR
INTENTION TO DO THEM IN.
THAT WE WERE FOLLOWING THE
FOOTSTEPS OF THE STORY.
AND SO I STARTED SPEAKING QUITE
A LOT THAT YEAR, 1972 -- WELL,
PROBABLY LATER 1973 AND 1974.
BRIAN: IN THE SHORT TIME
REMAINING, LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
PRESIDENTS BECAUSE THERE ARE
PICTURES IN HERE WITH YOU WITH
EVERY PRESIDENT SINCE LYNDON
JOHNSON.
JOHN KENNEDY.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF JOHN
KENNEDY?
KATHARINE: I FOUND HIM
IRREISTABLY CHARMING, AFRACTIVE
AND IT WAS EXCITING HAVING
SOMEONE YOU KNEW AS PRESIDENT.
HAVING YOUR GENERATION IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
HAVING THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
THERE, I THOUGHT THEY WERE
MARVELOUS.
BRIAN: HOW IS HE TODAY IN
RETROSPECT?
KATHARINE: I THINK IN THE THREE
YEARS HE HAD BEFORE HE DIED, I
DON'T THINK HE HAD THE CHANCE
TO REALLY GET AN AWFUL LOT DONE
OF WHAT HE WAS FRYING TO DO.
I THINK THAT -- TRYING TO DO.
I THINK PRESIDENT JOHNSON
EXCEEDED HIM AND GETTING
LEGISLATION PASSED THAT HE
WANTED TO GET DONE.
BRIAN: LYNDON JOHNSON UNDRESSED
IN FRONT OF YOU ONE NIGHT?
KATHARINE: THAT WAS A FUNNY
STORY BECAUSE I WAS AT HIS 34TH
WEDDING ANNIVERSARY AND JUST AS
WE WERE -- HE WAS IN A PRETTY
BAD MOOD ANYWAY.
IT WAS DURING THE VIETNAM WAR.
AND AFTERWARDS WE WENT UPSTAIRS
AND HE JUST WENT TO BED AND
LEFT US.
HIS BEDROOM ODDLY WAS RIGHT
NEXT DOOR TO THE UPSTORES
LIVING ROOM, THE YELLOW ROOM,
AND THERE WERE SOME DOUBLE
DOORS BETWEEN.
SUDDENLY HE CAME OUT -- WE WERE
SAYING GOOD NIGHT TO MRS.
JOHNSON.
THE DOORS FLUNG OUT AND HE
SAID, COME HERE.
I LOOKED OVER MY SHOULDER
HOPING SOMEBODY WAS THERE BUT
HE WAS SAYING IT TO ME.
THEN HE SAID, COME HERE.
ABE, WHO I BELIEVE WAS ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
AND WE WENT INTO HIS BEDROOM
AND "THE POST" WAS LYING ON THE
BED AND A MAN, THE CHIEF
COMMISSIONER IN THE DISTRICT --
THERE WERE STILL THREE -- BUT
HE WAS KIND OF LIKE THE
APPOINTED MAYOR.
HE WAS OUR -- FROM THE JOHNSON
POINT OF VIEW, HE WAS OUR
CREATION.
AND HE HAD APPOINTED A POLICE
COMMISSIONER WITHOUT CONSULTING
THE PRESIDENT WHICH HE HAD TOLD
HIM TO DO.
AND HE WAS VERY DISPLEASED
BECAUSE HE WANTED TO PROVE
SOMETHING ABOUT BEING
ANTI-CRIME BY APPOINTING A
SUPERPOLICE COMMISSIONER.
SO HE WAS REALLY MAD HE HAD
GONE AHEAD AND DONE THIS.
AND HE STARTED YELLING AT ME
ABOUT OUR GODDAMN MAYOR AND IT
WAS OUR IDEA AND HADN'T ASKED
HIM.
HE WANTED TO DO IT.
AND HE STARTED TO UNDRESS.
THIS IS 1964, PLEASE.
AND I WAS NEW TO THE JOB.
I HAD ONLY GONE TO WORK.
HE IS SLINGING HIS CLOTHES OFF
WHILE HE'S CALLING ME OUT.
AND I THOUGHT, WAIT A MINUTE.
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN HERE?
CAN THIS BE ME?
AM I STANDING HERE IN THE
PRESIDENT'S BEDROOM AND WHAT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN?
HE SUDDENLY SAID, TURN AROUND.
AND SO I TURNED AROUND.
HE WENT RIGHT ON.
AND FINALLY HE SAID, ALL RIGHT.
GOOD NIGHT.
WE BOTH LEFT.
I MEAN, IT WAS QUITE A
BEGINNING.
BRIAN: RICHARD NIXON.
KATHARINE: I NEVER KNEW HIM
REALLY.
PERSONALLY.
I MET HIM AND I TALKED TO HIM
AND I EVEN INTERVIEWED HIM AND
HE CAME TO LUNCH AT THE PAPER,
AN EDITORIAL LUNCH.
SO I SAW HIM A LITTLE BIT BUT I
DIDN'T REALLY KNOW HIM
PERSONALLY.
AND I THINK THAT HE HAD MANY
GOOD TRAITS.
I THINK HE WAS A REALLY JEKYLL
HYDE CHARACTER BECAUSE HE HAD
ALL THESE THINGS THAT WE KEEP
SEEING COME OUT ON THE TAPESAND
HE WAS REALLY BRILLIANT IN MANY
WAYS, AND HE HAD MANY GOOD
PEOPLE WORKING FOR HIM.
I REALLY VIEW HIM WITH APPLE
BIFF LENS.
-- AMBIVILENCE.
BRIAN: CONLED REAGAN.
KATHARINE: I DON'T THINK YOU
DON'T GET TO BE FRIENDS WITH A
PRESIDENT IF YOU DON'T KNOW HIM
BEFORE BECAUSE THEIR POWER IS
SO GREAT.
THEY SEE PEOPLE AS STRANGERS.
SO I THOUGHT HE WAS -- HE WAS A
LEADER.
WE KNEW WHAT HE STOOD FOR.
I THINK HE IS A VERY DIGNIFIED
MAN.
I WASN'T PARTICULARLY -- I
DIDN'T AGREE WITH HIM OR ALL
THAT HE DID BUT NANCY WAS A
GOOD FRIEND AND STILL IS.
BRIAN: BILL CLINTON.
-- BRIAN: BILL CLINTON?
KATHARINE: THERE ARE PROMISES
AND FAILURES.
I AM VERY HOPEFUL THINGS WILL GO
WELL AND I CERTAINLY HOPE THEY
DO.
BRIAN: YOU SAY YOU DO NOT SEE
MUCH OF HIM OR HAVEN'T.
KATHARINE: THEY ARE ANOTHER
GENERATION, VERY POLITE.
I HAVE SEEN THEM A LITTLE BIT
AND WE HAVE A MUTUAL FRIEND.
BUT THERE IS NO REASON THAT I
SHOULD SEE THEM.
BRIAN: YOU WERE WRITING A BOOK.
KATHARINE: I AM NOT A
PROFESSIONAL WRITING.
-- WRITER.
YET I WANTED TO WRITE.
I THOUGHT I WOULD GET TOO JUMPY
AND TELL HIM WHAT TO DO TOO
MUCH.
IT WAS HARD TO DO IT.
BRIAN: WHERE DID YOU WRITE IT?
KATHARINE: AT HOME AT MY DESK BY
HAND.
BRIAN: BY HAND?
THEN WHAT DID YOU DO?
KATHARINE: I GIVE IT TO MY
RESEARCHER WHO PUT IT ON A
COMPUTER AND IN ORDER AND HELPED
ME SHAPE IT AND MAKE CHAPTERS OF
IT, HELPED ME GET IT TOGETHER.
HE WAS FAIRLY ESSENTIAL.
THEN WE SENT IT OFF TO THE
EDITOR WHO LEFT HALF OF IT ON
THE CUTTING ROOM FLOOR.
BRIAN: I WANTED TO ASK YOU, 625
PAGES -- DID THEY USE ALL THE
WROTE?
KATHARINE: IT MAY HAVE BEEN
1200.
BRIAN: IS THERE A SECOND BOOK?
KATHARINE: NOPE, THAT IS IT.
BRIAN: ARE YOU LOOKING FORWARD
TO YOUR TOUR ACROSS THE COUNTRY?
KATHARINE: SORT OF.
BRIAN: WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
TALKING POINTS?
KATHARINE: IT IS HARD FOR ME,
MUCH HAVE HER -- MUCH HARDER
THAN HAVING WRITTEN.
BRIAN: WHY?
KATHARINE: I DO NOT KNOW.
TALKING ABOUT IT IN PUBLIC I
FIND VERY HARD.
I'M NOT VERY GOOD AT IT, EITHER,
AS YOU CAN NOW SEE.
BRIAN: KATHARINE GRAHAM IS OUR
GUEST.
THE BOOK IS CALLED "PERSONAL
HISTORY."
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]
>> TOMORROW, A